we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
you guys are going to love this um i
have this furious
trumpist jimmy from philly who calls in
and um he is very much like an anti
uh bernie sanders anti-left type guy
he doesn't like handouts he wants people
to
pull themselves up by their bootstraps
and all that typical stuff
he heard that i was getting a new
microphone and indeed if you're watching
today today is the first day with my new
shure sm7b i know it doesn't sound
perfect yet but
we're we're working on it and so jimmy
called
and he said hey can i have your old
microphone for free take a listen to
this
david jimmy from philly i hear you're
getting a new microphone
right uh how about let me have the old
one
i'll pay shipping yeah so uh
jimmy wants free stuff what has jimmy
done to earn
my evre20 which i've used for
10 years if i'm going to get honestly
we've been thinking should we auction
off i've used that microphone for 10
years
it still works perfectly i could sign
the microphone with a sharpie or not i
mean if people don't want it
we could auction it off for example
and do something interesting i'm going
to send it
to a furious trumpist who i've had to
kick off of my phone lines
for his virulently homophobic statements
that's who i'm going to send a 500
microphone to so jimmy first of all why
not figure out
how to pull yourself up by your
bootstraps and get yourself a microphone
you don't have to spend 500 bucks like
on an evr e20
micro you can get a 20 microphone okay
jimmy so that's first of all you don't
have to come
begging me for handouts and number two
if i'm gonna give the microphone to
someone not going to give it to someone
who calls in and says such disgusting
things you know i appreciate hearing
from people from all sides jimmy and
your calls are welcome but a free
microphone
come on it seems like it's a little bit
of entitlement
that i'm hearing there so no uh maybe we
will auction it off and maybe jimmy will
win
but i am unable jimmy to send you a free
500
microphone i apologize for that on the
bonus show today
donald trump has signed an executive
order or
executive as i've heard some people say
i say executive order
on drug prices a planet fitness
a gym chain is now going to start
requiring
members and guests to wear masks in
their gyms at all times this is
infuriating a lot of gym goers and we
will also talk about what some are
calling hygiene
theater hygiene theater now i'm not
talking about masks but i'm talking
about
some other elements of hygiene that
there are even
medical experts saying this is hygiene
theater if it makes us
feel better okay but from the standpoint
of actual science
some of the things that are being done
or recommended around the virus are
merely theater merely optics we will
talk about that on the bonus show as
well
how do you get access to the bonus show
beautiful perfect question
two ways number one get a membership at
joinpakman.com
number two become a patron at
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow you can get the bonus
show the commercial free audio and video
streams of the show
and so much more today later today
i will likely be live streaming if you
want to join me on youtube or twitch and
very exciting we are scheduled to
surpass
900 000 youtube subscribers today
by the time you hear today's show listen
to this episode
we may already be there and then the
race to a million begins
and i will talk to you more about that
on an upcoming program